amid the confusion and uncertainty the
lockdowns and protests all around the
world you may have noticed a curious
development over the past few months
cheaper gasoline due to a glut of oil
and fewer people on the roads gas has
become a lot more affordable here in
Texas were paying as little as a dollar
50 per gallon but well it's good for
motorists tends to be bad for the oil
companies many of which now have a
crisis on their hands a growing wave of
restructurings and bankruptcies already
a number of oil companies including
California natural resources Ultra
petroleum filled with energy and Diamond
offshore have announced restructurings
in just the past month and plenty more
are said to be preparing chapter 11
filings including the one-time champion
of American oil and gas fracking
Oklahoma city-based Chesapeake Energy
which has more than nine billion dollars
in long-term debt
Cobin 19 has only made existing problems
worse for many industries oil is no
different
BP is set to slash 10,000 jobs Chevron
and Halliburton are cutting tens of
thousands more oil consultancy rystad
predicts that 73 international oil
companies could go under in 2020 and 150
more are at risk for 2021 some of these
companies are entering bankruptcy
restructuring for the second time in
less than five years after the 2016 oil
bust Ken Coleman who runs the
restructuring practice at the law firm
Allen & Overy says there's one key
difference this time around when the oil
and gas industry last visited bankruptcy
courts on the large scale prices were
down but there was an ability to project
or at least people were comfortable that
they had an ability to project future
value and then through the bankruptcy
court and the bankruptcy process and the
restructuring process they could
allocate that value among the various
interest groups creditors secured
creditors unsecured creditors and equity
the ability to project using the tools
of financial an hour
are not but they're just not equipped to
deal with this kind of situation the
difference now is the inability to value
things and to project what their value
may be 12 24 36 months out the Federal
Reserve may help delay the wave of
restructurings through its 750 billion
dollar bond buying program and banks
have also shown a willingness to extend
and pretend in other words they're
allowing borrowers to slide on their
payments for a few months Chris Atherton
is the president of energy net which is
kind of like an eBay for oil fields he
expects to see a wave of oil fields
coming up for sale over the next six to
twelve months but it won't be completely
like before I think the strategy going
forward for a lot of companies is going
to be kind of a shrink to grow many are
gonna be in survival mode they're gonna
do take a lot of different measures and
steps to reduce expenses for their
operations and really try to survive and
maybe be the last man standing or last
you know in a smaller group believe
there's 75 or 80 publicly traded oil and
gas companies of size right now thinking
unfortunately and you know it could be
half that number and a year or two from
now and I think it'll be companies that
shrink by reducing their staff by laying
off people by reducing their drilling
activity there may be selling off some
production but if they do remain if they
do survive I think they'll be better and
stronger to fight another day down the
road and I think there will be quite a
few companies that just simply won't be
around and three four years
you